[Musique]
bonjour à tous et en particulier à
nathan qui se vante d'être le prof
effectivement sur le site du figaro vous
êtes bien sûr figaro live en direct dans
les studios du figaro on attend donc vos
points de vue en particulier sur la
polémique autour des dernières mesures
visant à stopper la propagation de
l'épidémie du copic 10,9
on va les confronter avec ce soir de
sophie de menthon bonsoir sophie chefs
d'entreprise et figurent entre autres de
l'opération j'aime ma boîte c'est le 15
octobre
toutes les infos sur le site j'aime ma
boîte points comme c'est la fête des
entreprises et face à vous adrian matou
journaliste à marianne qui pose une
question passionnante et qui fâche la
science et l vendus réponse en kiosque
vous en aurez pour votre argent l'autre
débat trouvez vous que jean castex est
un premier ministre à la hauteur c'est
la question qu'on pose sur youtube et
sur twitter avant le grand oral du
premier ministre ce soir sur france 2 on
en débat
juste après mais d'abord voilà je tourne
les feuilles
approuvez-vous les dernières mesures du
gouvernement ça c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur le site du figaro alors je
vais regarder où on en est et en à la mi
journée il y avait une légère vous êtes
très nombreux à voter sur le site du
figaro et à répondre à cette question en
début à la mi journée il y avait nette
majorité pour dire oui au début de cette
émission le léger
léger avantage encore oui c'est encore
le cas mais ça diminue de minute en
minute et ça diminue d'heure en heure
parmi les commentaires qu'on peut lire
sous justement cette question qui est
posée sur le site de figaro on peut
trouver ces commentaires tout ça ne
servira à rien sauf à détruire
l'économie
il faut laisser circuler le virus est
confiné les personnes à risque
al'inverse quelqu'un qui est favorable
les faits et les résultats ne ment pas
et ne sont pas mauvaises fois la france
se situe au 16e rang des nations pour
mort que vif 19 par million d'habitants
derrière les états unis derrière le
brésil derrière la grande bretagne
derrière l'espagne d'ariary suite
derrière l'italie derrière la suède
derrière l'italie cela prouve la bonne
gestion estime en tout cas cet
internaute de l'épidémie en france
alors c'est pas l'avis des élus de
marseille
à commencer par le premier adjoint de
noix païens qui à la mi journée ne
décolérait pas écouté avec madame la
maire je demande au gouvernement dix
jours avant la mise en place de
nouvelles mesures si à la fin de la
semaine prochaine les indicateurs
repartent à la hausse
nous serons prêts à prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent et qui seront
alors comprise par tout le monde il faut
tu 1ér hâtivement que les mesures de
l'état soient gelés alors il faut que
les mesures de l'état soit gelée renaud
muselier ne va pas aussi loin mais le
président les républicains de la région
paca déplore aussi le manque de
concertation avec les de la part des
autorités gouvernementales et
conteste également les mesures qui ont
été faits et cette unanimité on observe
également du côté de la france en se
disant on observe également du côté du
rassemblement national stéphane ravier
et d'une marseille ou encore jordan bar
des halles c'est une décision qui
m'apparaît injuste paye aujourd'hui des
incohérences et je trouve ça si vous
voulez un peu injuste de faire payer à
l'ensemble de la restauration ce type de
ce type de mesures alors il vivait en
lui ont semblé prendre conscience des
cas des conséquences de sa décision hier
dans un tweet pour autant il a repris la
parole à la mi journée devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
gestion du coronavirus et il assume sa
décision et enrayer la circulation du
virus protéger les hôpitaux protéger les
réanimations protéger et soulager les
soignants vu la vague épidémique que
nous avons connue dans notre pays ça
peut paraître agir en responsabilité et
je l'assumé et je l'assumerai à chaque
fois que ce sera nécessaire
alors olivier rey en assument adrien est
ce que c'est lui qui a pris cette
décision tout seul tout seul ça me
paraît hautement improbable
j'imagine qu'il a prises en concertation
avec le président emmanuel macron le
premier ministre jean castex
ceci dit c'est lui qui sait lui qui
porte la décision et c'est lui qui est
l'objet des foudres de
élus locaux après je vous avouerai que
moi j'ai un petit soupçon que je ne peux
pas étayés par des faits tangibles mais
je me demande si il ya eu si peu de
concertation que ça parce que olivier
verrons a quand même rappelé qu'ils
s'étaient rendus à marseille qu'il avait
dialogué avec les élus locaux
et quand on sait l'efficacité que peut
recouvrir l'anti parisianisme et
l'opposition à des mesures qui sont
décrits comme liberticide à marseille
par exemple
je me demande si l'ensemble des élus
marseillais n'en font pas un peu des
caisses entre guillemets pour surfer sur
la colère je sais pas si elle est
légitime mais la colère qui existe par
rapport à ces décisions là voilà jeu
j'aimerais un doute je pense que c'est
trop tôt pour le savoir mais j'aimerais
encaissés sur la curieuse parce que on
en entend des contestations à marseille
et on pourra lire ça dans le figaro dans
les prochaines heures de certains élus
qui dénoncent en tout cas d'élus
marseillais d'élus des bouches du rhône
qui disent que michel ribeiro la maire
de marseille et d'autres auraient dû
plus alerté le gouvernement mais
personne pour l'instant ne dit qu'il n'y
a pas eu concertée personne ne dit qu'il
ya eu concertation avec le gouvernement
quant à ses décisions oui alors il ya
peut-être effectivement un problème un
problème de dialogue ça ça me paraît
quand même assez évident parce que il
n'y a pas qu'à marseille et qu'on
dénonce ça je crois que anne hidalgo a
dit aussi qu'il y avait un manque de
dialogue il ya eu d'autres élus dans
dota d'hidalgo a dit qu'elle avait été
appelée par olivier ferrand une heure
avant l'annoncé de la de la décision et
l ua est là dit elle a exprimé son
désaccord
voilà alors à vérifier sur parce que
c'est vrai que si le gouvernement a
vraiment rappeler une heure pour juste
informé les élus locaux 2 des mesures
qui ont été prises
ce serait effectivement une erreur en
tout cas de peut-être pas une erreur
dans les mesures mais en tout cas une
erreur dans le dialogue après voilà moi
j'aurai toujours
enfin j'aurais toujours j'ai pour
l'instant ce petit doute sur le coût
politique qui serait de dire ouh là là
regardez ces élus jacobins parisien qui
nous impose des mesures iniques vous
avez ce doute également sophie compliqué
compliqué parce que d'abord un
évidemment qu'il faut consulter c'est
pas pour ça que ce qu'on va consulter
auront la bonne décision
je veux dire franchement c'est une
situation horrible mois difficiles
le ministre de la santé fait ce qui peut
moi ce que je sais c'est l'état des
hôpitaux avec une belle fille qui est
chef de service médecine interne kremlin
bicêtre qui me dit on à retransformer
mon service pour accueillir des malades
du code vide au cas où les urgentistes
qui ont donné leur démission elle qui
est médecin interne et ph qui est obligé
de faire le boulot des urgentistes donc
il ya la nécessité et on peut comprendre
l'objectif du ministre de la santé
il n'y a aucune espèce de raison que le
ministre de la santé ne protège pas les
hôpitaux et son ministère jeudi l'agencé
pas son problème ce qu'il faut
progressivement oui oui pardon je vous
coupe et j'aimerais avoir la réaction de
rien c'est que on comprend bien ce que
ce que vous dites
j'attendais que vous alliez voler tout
de suite au secours des entreprises et
des restaurateurs vous bavez à vous
m'avez un petit peu déconcerté non c'est
le plaisir de vous avoir un cheikh
sophie mais effectivement le monde
médical saluant tout cas la décision de
oui mais non mais attendez c'est si
terriblement compliqué c'est trop facile
de jeter l'anathème alors ensuite les
restaurateurs juste une seconde mais les
restaurateurs
il ya un truc qui était absolument
aberrant et moi je trouve que le
gouvernement devrait immédiatement
prendre ça en charge il n'y a pas de
pédagogie vous mettez hamas dans la rue
c'est inutile vous êtes à vélo vous ne
le mettez pas je lui mets pas quand je
suis à vélo je descends n'y a personne
dans la rue je ne mets pas par contre
vous arrivez à un restaurant vous vous
asseyez vous enlevez votre masse vous
êtes à côté de quelqu'un mais laissez
moi rigoler il n'est pas un mètre vingt
il est à 60 cm il se tourne vers vous il
est passionné et c'est là que ça se
passe
c'est l'alsace passe surtout et donc il
faut remettre ces masques quand on est
assis aux terrasses des cafés et même
entre les plats au restaurant c'est moi
qu'ils distincts conseils de bon sens
ensuite si on ferme à 10 heures
évidemment que c'est subite que 10h15 ou
10h20 ou 11 ans mais c'est l'alcool
c'est à dire que des tout le monde l'a
vu j'ai même vu à des dîners de copains
des vous avez pris deux verres de vin
vous embrasser tout le monde à la fin du
dîner en dix ans à lui donc vous avez
c'est un inhibiteur l'alcool mais ma
toute petite dose est pas des
alcooliques mais un bon dîner entre
copains on les connaît
et on se dit ah bah non et puis à la fin
il vous embrasse
et donc c'est ça le problème c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont mis des
heures comme ça parce que plus on avance
dans la nuit puis on picole qui mais
pourquoi pourquoi ya pas de pédagogique
24 10 minutes par jour à la télé avant
de parler de 10 minutes par jour de
d'écouté olivier ferrand peine dix
minutes par jour je vous reposer est ce
que je comprends très bien ce que vous
dites sur les sur les hôpitaux peut-être
d'ailleurs également votre point de vue
mais est-ce que pardonnez moi devons
poser la question comme ça mais est ce
que cette situation
la situation des hôpitaux et pour
protéger les hôpitaux on est en train de
paralyser des communards à ça la
question après le fait est que j'ai
pitot ces nous un oui alors ça c'est dit
oui mais est ce qu'on est en train de
paralyser l'économie française le
problème c'est que encore une fois les
données sur les hôpitaux où elles sont
quand même assez préoccupante c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même des
départements c'est pour ça que je
voulais aussi rajouter ça il ya
peut-être un sentiment de persécution à
marseille mais les décisions n'ont pas
été prises au doigt mouillé selon qu'on
aime bien ou pas les les régions elles
ont été prises sur des chiffres taux
d'incidence de lancer dans chez les
personnes âgées et services de
réanimation temps aussi il est par de
moins alors il est en baisse à marseille
effectivement wheels ne vais pas citer
la villa sort mais il est quand même
beaucoup plus élevés à marseille que
dans les autres villes qui ne sont pas
en alerte maximale donc encore une fois
moi je trouve ça assez en fait c'est un
peu compliqué parce que les
restaurateurs je les comprends côté ils
défendent leurs intérêts entre
guillemets les restaurateurs n'ont pas
vocation à gérer la cie que la santé
publique des français or le gouvernement
doit faire un arbitrage entre la santé
publique des français l'état de
l'économie
ceci dit il y aura quand même un soutien
économique bruno le maire a déjà a déjà
promis qui aurait un soutien économique
pour les pour les restaurateurs
un peu plus loin oui mais enfin les ce
que je veux dire c'est que les
entreprises
c'est effectivement difficile mais elles
ont quand même été soutenu il ya eu
comme un final elle il ya le plan de
relance devra cesser
elle jouera le laisser dans l'eau et il
ya quand même je suis désolé il ya les
restaurateurs on ferme les jeunes ou pas
jeunes ou moins jeunes à la terrasse la
fête tout le monde en proximité pas de
masque et au picole à 11 heures du soir
si les gens étaient raisonnables ça se
passerait pas on ne serait pas obligé de
prendre ça je dire je ne comprends pas
qu'on n'est pas beaucoup plus appeler
communiqué
s'il n'y avait pas eu d injonctions
contradictoires permanente je leur parle
oui je pense que le problème ça vient le
problème fondateur c'est le mensonge
mais oui les masses qui m'est absolument
et à partir de ce moment là les gens ont
perdu toute confiance cette confiance
envers lui compris les tests a aussi
version hébergée par les entreprises je
veux donner des tests salivaires et des
tests sérologiques pour savoir si les
gens des anticorps personne ne m'a
répondu au gouvernement un peu cher
celui tout le monde est ce que j'ai le
droit nous voulons les deux nés là nos
salariés pas le droit pas le droit c'est
comme les masques au début confisqués
donc si vous voulez ya un manque de bon
sens de cohérence qui fait que en plus
on n'interpelle pas les gens en faisant
appel à leur vraie responsabilité
personnelle
moi je sais faire surtout quand on a
écouté la première porte parole du
gouvernement
si bêtes qui était auditionné au sénat
et qui n'a même pas été capable de dire
ben oui je me suis planté
elle a encore dit qu elle encore dit
qu'on était immature et incompétents et
qu'on connaît pas la stylisation c'est
ça parce qu on a l'impression que
finalement le des autorités le
gouvernement ne ne tire pas les leçons
ils sont ma mais l'activisme avait des
premiers mois en fait je sais pas c'est
une question de tirer les leçons ou
plutôt de traîner comme un boulet n'ont
pas de courage ils sont mauvais alors je
serai ça c'est pas le goût vraiment moi
je trouve que les donneurs décision qu'a
prise comprise 4 isoler les gérants ne
sont pas de bellion d'envoi non c'est
pas ça que je critique ce que je
critique c'est l'aspect volontairement
politiques de tous la peur ne pas être
élu la volonté quand on est dans un
parti de dire le contraire de ce que dit
l'autre il n'y a pas eu d'unité
nationale l'opposition a flingué à l'erl
m
ne parlons pas de mélenchon et marine le
pen et franchement on est à un moment
et d'ailleurs il l'a dit dans le midi ou
non il y aurait une unité nationale
nécessaire stop il faut venir à bout de
cette épidémie et il faut avoir un peu
de raison et quand on n'est pas capable
ça c'est une question de courage
personnel quand on n'est pas capable de
dire écoutez porte-parole oui j'aurais
pas dû dire ça j'ai eu
or je me suis trompé on fera pas ça il
n'y a aucune vérité dans leur langage
parce que je reviens pardonnez moi c'est
un peu une idée fixe mais cette mesure
de l'île et vers ans et qui est salué ce
qui est je trouve très troublant par
vraiment le corps médical et dans son
ensemble et les responsables
hospitaliers
vous parliez justement d'où peut-être
une forme de démagogie et d'un sincérité
de la part des élus marseillais est ce
que il n'y a pas non plus chez l'ancien
syndicaliste médicale vers en un coup
justement visant à avoir une popularité
à faire plaisir aux médecins au
détriment des autres corps de
nationaux des autres corps économique il
est plus populaire auprès des médecins
que des restaurateurs
c'est assez clair entre votre ironie
ouais mais mais ceci dit c'est pas
facile du mal à imaginer que les gérants
prennent ce [ __ ] je pense vraiment que
pour le coup jean castex et emmanuel
macron ont quand même chapeauté ces
décisions là ça m'étonnerait je pense
pas qu'on joue les médecins contre les
restaurateurs je pense assez simple que
ça est ce que quand samia ghali 10 pour
sortir paris de l'urgence on met
marseille dans l'urgence ça illustre ce
que je disais au début de l'émission
annoncée jusqu'à marseille les données
sont plus préoccupants qu'à paris et
comprend du coup des mesures drastiques
ceci dit à paris il ya quand même des
mesures assez drastique qui sont prises
aussi donc là voilà moi je pense qu'elle
peut elle essaie de flatter un petit peu
le le l'antagonisme par et marseille
mais c'est pas trés sarine et puis alors
les réunions parce qu'on va revenir
aussi un peu lente reprise les réunions
interdites les cabinets de ce délai et
société de sport fermée etc
je ne comprends pas la cohérence et les
mêmes prennent le métro le matin il se
tourne vers ses parents sont plus
dangereux que les transports en
ile-de-france puis même que les
ivoiriens dans les transports ils
s'embrassent pas ils boivent pas ils ont
des masses qui déjà se raidit les
entreprises peuvent être un lieu de
contamination les vachement gaffe
non mais bien sûr mais c'est juste que
naturellement il ya des gens qui se
retrouvent dans un même espace donc
c'est compliqué les écoles les dernières
études ne prouve pas que le que le virus
ne circule pas entre les jeunes et
pourtant il y avait un assouplissement
des protocoles à l'école je sais aussi
que j'ai lu dans le figaro donc c'est
tout à fait faisable
je sais que les lieux de culte de rester
ouvert à aix et à marseille alors que
c'est vrai par exemple il ya des saveurs
vous êtes d'accord a effectivement d'un
journaliste de marianne il veut fermer
les lieux cultes mais ceci dit par
exemple c'est pas du tout pour cibler
tel ou tel secteur mais par exemple il
ya des salles de sport qui vont fermer
alors alors qu'elles ont des protocoles
beaucoup plus citer que les écoles de
reprise certains lieux de culte donc ses
sources dans le lieu de culte est que
voulait fréquentais pas beaucoup je peux
vous dire qu'il ya des protocoles
énoncer ces protocoles sont strictes et
d'épurer ils sont comme ça
bien sûr c'est pas ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il viendra chez vous intéresse
le plus les évêques de france dont je
vous laisse la responsabilité propre et
un constat mais ce genre dans certains
lieux
c'est ça qui pose à l'église des gens
ils sont sages ils bougent pas ils sont
loin de la personne d'un côté savent
même plus la main dans l'église
catholique
il ya dans le temple dans les mots sera
là mais il ya des endroits et ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est que dans toutes
ses décisions il n'y a pas du tout de
prise en considération de la
responsabilité individuelle et de la
réalité de ce qui se passe
peut-être qu'il y a eu et que le
gouvenement été déçus justement du
comportement des français
c'est un peu ça parce que je vais faire
il est aidé c'est un peu le message
qu'ils étaient par exemple sur les
plages étaient de quatre derniers sur
une classe à part contre vous oblige à
metz d'extraordinaire j'avais quelqu'un
à 30 mètres sur la plage l'équipe et les
à masquer je reviens sur avant de
conclure sur ce que tous ces chiffres
qui circulent
est ce qu'on n'est pas pardonnez moi de
le dire
victime d'un effet de loupe et d'un
effet de projection on voit des courbes
on a montré une courbe notamment lundi
du nombre de décès qui a
considérablement décru mais enfin c'est
on avait atteint un pic à ma mère c'est
un plateau mais c'est un plateau bas
donc ça fait comme ça et je lis la cd
confrères qui donne ce chiffre qui dit
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées a
bondi de 405 à 515 patients dans les
bouches-du-rhône 515 oui c'est un bon
deal quand même enfin c'est pas le
basque bondissant et c'est pas non plus
enfin de là à prendre des mesures aussi
forte que oui mais c'est pas excessif si
si il est possible qu'ils ont fait il ya
13 me de nouvelles contaminations en 24
heures il ya quand même quatre mille 200
à 250 personnes qui ont été
hospitalisées ces derniers jours c'est
il ya aussi des chiffres qui je pense
que les chiffres pour l'instant ne sont
pas extrêmement grave mais que le
gouvernement cherche à couper l'herbe
sous le pied de stopper la remontée des
courbes en fait alors il ya quand même
un vrai problème et j'aimerais bien
qu'on poser la question des
scientifiques mondy expliqué c'est le
cas d'ailleurs aux états unis les tests
sont très sensibles c'est à dire que
vous faites des pistes et s'est
multiplié par trente ans vous détecte un
bout de virus c'est pour ça que nous
avons un nombre des gens est
symptomatique très étonnant j'espère que
c'est le cas d'ailleurs de notre
ministre des finances je crois que ça
l'est
c'est donc haut des pistes énormément de
cas d'où la panique alors là dedans y en
a mais ceux qui sont vraiment malades
c'est encore les personnes très âgées
et donc là aussi il ya on peut avoir des
doutes là dessus et puis aussi une
question très importante qui irrite
profondément les gens
expliquez-moi pourquoi je trouve ça
inadmissible qu'on interdise aller voir
sa vieille maman sa vieille grand mère
etc attendent et pourquoi est ce que le
personnel soignant équipée peut
approcher et soigner tous les jours des
personnes âgées
et pourquoi avec le même équipement
leurs enfants ne pourraient pas
approcher ces personnes âgées vraie
question on y reviendra peut-être
justement dans d'autres dans d'autres
débats et sur la sur la prise en charge
justement des personnes âgées
je donne la parole à nos internautes
sofia sur le fil site du figaro que ce
gouvernement m'expliquer pourquoi on
accepte une manifestation interdite à
damas de 5000 personnes et d'un autre
côté les personnes assises sur les
terrasses dérange nathan qui nous dit
j'étais contre le confinement février a
fortiori je le reste on n'a plus les
moyens pour ces mesures dingue à nous
sur le site du figaro également pourquoi
en huit mois les capacités de en réa
n'ont pas été considérablement augmentés
là vous opiné je te vois mon cher adrian
a augmenté elles ont augmenté mais c'est
vrai que voir qu'on est déjà quasiment
saturation à certaines zones
alors qu'il ya quand même beaucoup moins
deux cas quand en avril ça pose question
c'est vrai quand même et philippe donc
qui me disais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi les restaurants sont plus
dangereux que les transports en ile de
france
on l'a déjà donné babineau je ne suis
pas d'accord il ne faut pas opposer
l'économie l'aspect sanitaire la
priorité c'est d'éviter un recond
finement généralisée et n'attendent dit
les invités considérez vous que le refus
de porter le masque constitue une mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui au sens du
code j'imagine que ça doit être du code
pénal non oui il ya des pots refusé de
porter le masque dans une situation à
risque oui là en mai sur la plage ne
mets pas mon masque oui enfin sur la
place si elle n'est pas bondée wii la
wii mais elle est obligatoire donc
c'est intéressant ce que ce que vous
dites comme souvent et est ce que vous
considérez pas que finalement la la
mesure la plus sage serait si vous avez
si vous avez peur ou si vous êtes
personnes à risques c'est vous qui
devriez mettre un masque bien sûr mais
c'est le cas c'est demander à chaque
citoyen d'auto évaluer ce le fait qu'il
soit à risque ou pas mais il n'y a pas
de gens qui se conservent pas risques
qui pourraient contaminer les autres
s'ils mettaient pas de masque non mais
alors attendez il ya deux choses
premièrement il ya différents types de
masques je sais que par exemple quand je
voyage voyager en avion je mets les
risques les masques qui sont spécialisés
hôpitaux mfp de nom oui c'est ça qui la
protège les autres de moi et me protège
moi même ça c'est le masque quand on est
à risque soit même qu'on devrait porter
tout le temps il y en a pas deux ans
vous en vend pas dans l toujours pas
pratiquement dans les pharmacies c'est
invraisemblable
c'est le mas qui protège une personne et
qui protège l'autre donc il est évident
qu'on éviterait nommément de choses donc
il ya déjà la nature du masque ensuite
de sa un masque protège l'autre aussi
donc c'est une auto protection mais
protège l'autre de vous même et ne vous
protège pas on continuera de toute façon
le débat je pense que sur la question
des masses qui n'est pas épuisée et puis
on attendra les rapports au pire du des
commissions d'enquêté parlementaire sur
la question approuvez-vous les nouvelles
mesures de restriction annoncées par le
gouvernement c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur le site du figaro vous
pouvez continuer à voter vous êtes des
nombreux de très nombreux à voter et
vous pouvez continuer à voter parce que
pour l'instant personne n'est départager
c'est jean baptiste émergents qui
m'indique 50 50 alors ce que je vois
c'est léger avantage pour le oui 50 22
contre 49,78 et j'approuve j'en sais
rien et vous je m'étonne de ce constat
mois sur ce sondage donc c'est compliqué
il ya pas cette possibilité
pendant les loisirs on est embêté jean
castex est il à la hauteur peut-être que
ça c'est une question à laquelle vous
pourrez répondre manche et adrien c'est
l'autre question qu'on pose cette fois
ci sur twitter et sur youtube
jean castex est un homme remarquable
c'est un vrai chef c'est un vrai leader
ça c'est une confidence que nous a fait
un de ses anciens collaborateurs au
ministère de la santé où ils avaient eux
devraient pourtant les français n'ont
pas en majorité ne partagent pas en
majorité cette vision alors est ce que
c'est votre avis quel est votre avis
dites le nous en tout cas dans les
sondages on voit que seuls 46% des
français ont une opinion positive du
premier ministre trois mois après son
arrivée à matignon et vous le voyez au
même moment à la même époque
edouard philippe lui recueilli 5 points
de plus à 51%
et quand on regarde un petit peu plus
dans le sondage aux hawks à denso
consulting pour le figaro et france info
on voit que 61% des français pensent que
les trois premiers mois de jean castex
ne sont pas une réussite contre 39%
alors vous quel est votre avis vous nous
le donner le vôtre sophie de menthon il
est à la hauteur il n'est pas à la
hauteur
franchement sur quelles bases alors je
suis très contente de votre sondage mais
juger s'il est à la hauteur ou pas
la situation est terrible
il a pris les décisions collectives
qu'il fallait prendre est en fait le
jugement ce qui est très embêtant c'est
que c'est fondé sur ses capacités à
communiquer est ce qu'il est bon ou pas
bon ce soir ça va vraiment être le sujet
il efface david lisnard le maire de
cannes que je trouve exceptionnel il va
avoir des gens qui veulent en poser des
questions il n'a pas été formé je suis
désolé il ya du training à faire quand
on a la france entière qui vous écoute
devant un micro il faut avoir de la
répartie il avait de l'humour
notre dernier premier ministre mais là
bon son accent on a trouvé ça
sympathique je dire c'est uniquement là
dessus que les gens vont se fonder parce
que on ne sait pas ce que ça a donné ses
trois premiers mois
je ne sais pas quel est le résultat les
boîtes vont pas si mal
économiquement on était reprenez pas mal
j'étais plutôt mieux que ce qu'on avait
estimé or confie non là on tape un peu
malheureusement sur les restaurateurs et
c'est très douloureux mais
j'ai pas de critères pour dire si si si
les bourgs ou pas bon j'ai pas de
critères est-ce que vous avez décrite en
rien la liste police j'ai peut-être un
petit peu reformuler la question est ce
qu'il est à la hauteur
alors il n'est pas très haut mais je
pense qu'il est à l'auteur parfaite pour
emmanuel macron en fait c'est ça la
subtilité du truc c'est que et loire
philippe commençait sérieusement à faire
de l'ombre au président il était
beaucoup plus populaire que le président
ce qui est toujours problématique sous
la 5ème république
il a choisi quelqu'un qui est évidemment
moins charismatique quelle horreur
à oui j'en suis persuadé pour le racing
je pense vraiment que il ya eu 7
mais peut-être un désir de d'or philippe
de passer à autre chose et de le quitter
matignon oui je pense
mais il ya eu le choix délibéré de
prendre quelqu'un alors certes qui était
issu de la droite pour pouvoir continuer
son entreprise de sawija bordage de l
air mais aussi de prendre quelqu'un qui
est plus effacé qui est moins connu mais
pas précisé les mauvais il a une sale
tête liste sera pas populaire enfin vous
pouvez pas passer ça parce que un très
beau premier ministre c'est bon pour
macron je sais pas qui dit que sont jean
castex je pense pas que jean castex soit
mauvais je pense juste que c'est
quelqu'un qui ne fera pas d'ombré au
président qui va être quelqu'un qui va
être un bon exécutant
c'est quelqu'un qui a une carène
ministre hâtive absolument exemplaire il
a ce qu il a fait alors moi ça me navre
beaucoup moins que vous mais les
administratifs aussi que la france est
en train de mourir d'une véritable
embolie administrative on est incapable
de se réformer dans le plan de réforme
il y aurait dû avoir une somme consacrée
à la réforme de cette technostructure et
ça n'a pas été fait ça s'éteint
un problème terrible vous avez raison
c'est un administratif c'est un
fonctionnaire et ben moi j'ai pas envie
de ça je lui réponde sur ça le projet je
pense que le problème de jean castex et
qu' il ya eu deux fables qui ont été
racontées à son sujet quand il était
arrivé on a raconté que c'était un homme
des territoires de l'ex rihanna qui
s'appelait pour sarlat alors le problème
c'est qu'il suffit pas d'être bon alors
certes il est maire de prades dans les
pyrénées orientales donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est plus enracinée que la moyenne
des hauts fonctionnaires français mais
il suffit pas d'avoir un accent du sud
ouest et de dire territoire tous les
trois phrases pour être quelqu'un dans à
signer prouve que vous n'êtes pas du sud
ouest parce que prades les habitants de
prat vous diront que c'est pas dans le
sud ouest
oui il sait dans le mythe et la cnep oui
c'est l'ism castex dans les pyrénées
orientales
nantes l2 le havre c'était à nos racines
moi aussi mais en tout cas voilà c'est
un homme qui on a un petit peu surjouée
son côté terroir wilquin qui a été dans
les administrations toute sa vie qui est
cabinet de xavier bertrand
oui à biner de nicolas sarkozy est la
deuxième femme qui a été racontée et
quelques sophie sera moins d'accord avec
moi pour le coup mais c'est qu'il nous a
raconté qu'il était un gaulliste social
expression qui ne veut plus dire grand
chose rien alors qu'en réalité
moi je pense qu'il est plutôt proche de
vous sur le plan économique monsieur
monsieur jean castex il a été il a mis
en place la tarification à l'acte il a
toujours défendu une vision plutôt
libérale de l'économie
il a été très applaudi en allant voir le
medef l'autre jour habib
il a été quand même un bide sa folie aux
ptf ça a été saluée par la police
je suis désolé je crois évidemment a
salué le premier ministre deux mille
personnes et je suis désolé je suis
obligé de le dire s'est il a il n'a pas
été bon mais daf et il n'a pas été
appréciée mais c'était parce que d'abord
geoffroy roux de bézieux a ouvert et a
été très talentueux puis lui il a
l'habitude de ça il parlait à sa
clientèle
là il est arrivé un peu désarçonné il
n'a rien annoncé
rien donc là une des 1000 heures
supplémentaires de baisses d'impôts sur
les sociétés c'est quand même pas oui
mais attendez c'est pas le fond que je
juge c'est ça le problème est là
justement on est ronde et on est parti
sur le fond maintenant sur le fond et
les plus proches avant lui il n'a pas eu
le temps quand je suis arrivé tout était
fait avant lui je veux dire c'est qu'il
s'inscrit dans la continuité des menus
comme sur le plan économique oui je suis
un gaulliste social à mon avis il ya eu
un courant froid parce que vraiment tout
le monde a ricané oui ça pour quoi
parce que ça fait plus rien dire
d'ailleurs on est d'accord c'est
vraiment plus quoi on a ri que naît au
medef en entendant l'expression
gaulliste social parce que ça ne veut
rien dire combien passionnant parce que
sinon on n'aime pas le gold et non parce
que les gens n'osent pas critiquer le
gaulliste quels qu'ils soient sociales
ou pas mais c'est complètement l'autre
le monde d'avant enfin d'avant d'avant
ben moi je vous conseille un article sur
marianne sur justement on a un petit peu
exploré cette notion de gaullisme social
et on a tenté de démontrer par a plus b
en se référant aux écrits du général de
gaulle que jean castex ne correspondait
pas à cette définition n'est que
gaullisme social était un pléonasme mais
oui c'est vrai il a inventé la sécurité
site de gaulle était sociale et à
l'intéressement non le sien je dis ça
parce qu'eux aussi ont dit que de gaulle
avait pas des rapports quand même très
chaleureux avec le patronat non non
c'était pas du tout chaleureux
d'ailleurs personne rapport avec le
patronat sauf ce gouvernement il faut
saluer emmanuel macron c'est le premier
à avoir eu un gouvernement pro
économique il avait envie de ça et
personne n'a jamais aimé les patrons on
était bien de changer de nom
c'était terrible enfin non le patronat
n'est pas aimé castex n'est qu'un
fusible pour emmanuel macron et nous dit
claudius et au fond castex et le dircab
de mâcon c'est le sens de ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure
rires oui alors fusible l'expression est
encore un petit peu comme moi je dirais
premier ministre de transition jusqu'en
2022 prémisse qui va servir à emmanuel
macron à gérer la fin du quinquennat
reeler il a des capacités de
gestionnaire reconnu jean castex mais ce
n'est pas un personnage politique points
alors d'abord il peut faire des progrès
parce que quand même quand on débarque
comme sa faim voix de nos entreprises
excusez moi on prend un dg il faudrait
qu'en l'espace de 2 15 jours il est
résolu les problèmes de l'entreprise
exter donc il va progresser c'est un
homme paraît-il autoritaire donc voilà
il arrive à perdre et il a toujours été
un exécutant maintenant il découvre
quand même le plaisir un peu d'eux
lorsqu'il en est par contre il
consultait pas beaucoup et il est même
très autoritaire je crois avec ses
équipes
donc on peut imaginer que
en tout cas ils s'opposent lors d'autres
disent que effectivement il sait mener
une équipe et il sait avoir une vision
pour ces équipes c'est ce que confier ce
haut fonctionnaire
la question qu'on vous posez c'est est
pensez vous que jean castex est un
premier ministre à la hauteur vous êtes
extrêmement sévère pour des noms à 69%
c'est un petit peu reculer parce que
l'auteur quand j'avais regardé ces 70%
maintenance et 69 donc peut-être que le
débat vous a rendu un petit peu plus
indulgent vous regarder ce soir jean
castela l'art et comment bon alors c'est
sur france télévisions mais voulait
suivre en live texte sur le site du
figaro avec les mômes déclaration les
moments clés sélectionnés par maxime
l'oreille pour figurer au live j'aime ma
boîte l'opération c'est le 15 octobre et
je me bats pour elle mais je m'affale
j'aime ma boîte points comme c'est
le site internet pour avoir toutes les
informations sur la fête de l'entreprise
mais vous aimez votre boîte aussi un
concours si vous permettez mon placement
de produit par la plus belle grâce une
entreprise voilà la plus belle lettre
d'amour il faut que les gens écrivent
une lettre d'amour à leur entreprise
n'ait pas trop alors salariés pourquoi
pas les salariés entre eux et je pense
que ça fait tellement de bien
pardon du salat les salariés aussi à
leur patron cédric alors j'aime ma boîte
je sais pas si j'irai jusque là
néanmoins le chemin boîtes noires si je
l'aimais je sais pas si j'irai jusqu'à
écrire une lettre d'amour à chaque
marianne marianne qui fait donc sa une
sur
la question qui pose une question qui
fâche la science et l vendus et on
signale également le nouveau numéro du
figaro magazine que vous allez trouver
très rapidement dans les prochaines
heures dans vos kiosques qui fait un
très beau numéro sur les forces
spéciales et la dgse avec un récit
inédit de vincent nouzille on se
retrouve nous demain même heure même
endroit avec le patron du figaro
magazine guillaume roquette a très vite
sur figaro live
[Musique]